هذه نتيجة مذهلة من
المجلس الوطني لسلامة النقل، وقد
أصدر للتو تقريرًا مكونًا من 19 صفحة، وهو
تقرير أولي عن هذا الانفجار
في الخامس من يناير، ويقول بشكل أساسي إن
البراغي التي كانت محور
هذا التحقيق منذ البداية
لم تكن موجودة.  هو النوع الفعلي
من الترباس، هذا الترباس A6 شائع جدًا
في الطيران، هذا هو الترباس نفسه، هناك صامولة
قلعة هنا ثم رقم
التعريف الشخصي المركزي للحفاظ على كل هذا معًا في
نقطة واحدة، كان هناك بعض التخمين بأن
دبوس كوتر ربما كان مفقودًا
من شأنه أن يتسبب في عمل هذا الجوز في
S free. في الواقع، يقول NTSB لم
يكن أي من هذه البراغي في مكانه وقت
هذا الانفجار الشهر الماضي، وكان NTSB
قادرًا على تحديد ذلك لأنهم
تمكنوا من استعادة سدادة الباب التي سقطت
قبالة ألاسكا  الرحلة 1282 في
الفناء الخلفي لمدرس الفيزياء في بورتلاند،
أحضروها إلى مختبرهم في العاصمة للقيام
بشيء يسمى الاختبار المدمر
وكانوا قادرين على معرفة ذلك من خلال
العلامات المنذرة الموجودة على الباب نفسه
وأيضًا على التركيبات هناك، حيث يمكنك رؤية
تلك العلامات.  على جانب الباب،
لم يتم تثبيت هذه البراغي ببساطة.
النظرية الجارية من
NTSB الآن هي أنه تم إخراج هذه البراغي
في وقت ما عندما كانت هذه الطائرة
جديدة جدًا، فقد طارت لأول مرة في نهاية
أكتوبر ولكن جسم الطائرة كان  تم تسليمه
من قبل مقاول من الباطن إلى Boeing في
الأول من سبتمبر
2023، لاحظ فنيو Boeing هناك
بعض المشكلات المتعلقة بالمسامير بجوار الباب
وتمكنوا من إزالة أجزاء من
الباب وقابس الباب وتمكن NTSB من
معرفة ذلك من الصور الملتقطة
للعمل  حدث ذلك في 19 سبتمبر
حيث لم يتم تثبيت البراغي،
وهذا يضيف المزيد من التدقيق أه إلى
بوينج أه الذي يتعرض حقًا
لضغوط كبيرة الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بمراقبة الجودة والسؤال الكبير
هنا هو سبب إزالة تلك البراغي
وسبب عدم إعادتهم إلى ذلك
هو الشيء الذي لا يزال NTSB
يحاول تحديده، فهم يريدون
معرفة ما هي التعليمات على
وجه التحديد والتي كانت موجودة في
أدلة التعليمات هناك
لعمال Boeing في مصنعها وإيجارها في
واشنطن الآن.  سمعت للتو من
مدير إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) أن هناك حوالي
عشرين مفتشًا من إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) يقومون
بإجراء تدقيق لمراقبة الجودة في شركة Boeing
ولكن هذه ليست سوى البداية،
وهذا مجرد تقرير أولي،
وسنرى تقريرًا نهائيًا على الأرجح في
غضون عام دون إلقاء اللوم هنا من قبل إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA)
NTSB على Boeing على الرغم من أننا يمكن أن نجد
ذلك في التقرير النهائي